avec sébastien leroy maire les
républicains de à mandelieu la napoule
bonjour monsieur leroi merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france alors
pour bien constituer un mandelieu la
napoule c'est à côté de cannes vous êtes
donc être directement concernés par les
restrictions concernant toute cette côte
azuréenne votre réaction dans un premier
temps est ce que c'était les bonnes
mesures à prendre mais à écouter est ce
que c'était les bonnes mesures à prendre
disons que nous sommes arrivés dans une
situation où aujourd'hui il ne reste
plus beaucoup d'options disponibles
puisque on n'a pas pris de mesures
pendant de très longues semaines en
dépit de nos demandes répétées et qu'on
s'est retrouvé au dernier moment ont mis
devant le fait accompli
est ce que vous pensez justement que ces
mesures prises localement sont aussi une
bonne solution plutôt que de prendre des
mesures à l'échelle nationale oui
écoutez je pense que effectivement de
faire du territoire c'est bien c'est
toujours sain plutôt que de la réponse
générale qui n'est pas forcément une
division alizés donc il faut faire du
cas par cas
maintenant le cas par cas ne peut
fonctionner aussi que s'il ya un suivi
national et une coordination annales
aujourd'hui on fait du cas par cas dans
la précipitation alors surtout sur les
alpes-maritimes puisqu'on était un peu
le laboratoire mais j'attends encore la
cohérence au niveau national notamment
en à provisions en approvisionnement par
des doses de vaccins et aux renforts de
forces de l'ordre parce que le
confinement de décréter lequel c'est
bien le faire respecter ces milieux on a
souvent entendu vos collègues vos de
plusieurs élus locaux demandés de la
part du gouvernement davantage de
responsabilités est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous sentez entendu de la part du
gouvernement justement on donne aux élus
locaux plus de responsabilités sur leur
territoire par rapport à ces à ces
mesures sanitaires
écoutez on affiche en tout cas qu'on
donne plus de responsabilités mais dans
la réalité on en est encore très loin
pour vous donner un exemple la
concertation au niveau du territoire
elle a été décrétée contre toute
atteinte samedi matin par le ministre de
la santé lorsqu'il est en visite à nice
il ya eu aucune préparation en amont il
ya eu aucune aucun avertissement que de
telles mesures seraient prises
on a été convoquée en catastrophe le
samedi soir en mesure conférence avec
toutes les difficultés techniques cela
peut engendrer puisqu'on était une
vingtaine d'élus du territoire puisque
les parlementaires pourrait changer en
l'espace d'une heure une heure et quart
dans une discussion générale fort
sympathique mais quand même peu
détaillées sur le terrain pour nous dire
qu'en gros demain le lendemain on
proposerait les mesures qui avaient déjà
été annoncées le matin même donc moi
c'est parce que j'entends par
concertation ni par délégation de
pouvoir ça ne peut fonctionner au niveau
national puis si vous ne faites
confiance aux élus territoriaux
parce que les élues locales connaissent
leurs villes connaissent le territoire
savent ce qu'il faut donner comme moyen
où il faut concentrer les efforts et moi
c'est ce que j'attendais mais la
concertation n'a pas du tout été fait
dans ce sens là donc il ya beaucoup
d'affichage de concertation mais on en
est encore très très loin dans la
réalité vous déplorez justement ce
manque de confiance de la part du
gouvernement
oui bah je le déplore parce que déjà un
il est pas nouveau ça fait des années
qu'on a des problèmes ce n'est pas
spécifiquement liés à ce gouvernement
s'était déjà cassé mon précédent mais il
faut quand même bien dire que depuis
2010 est ça s'est accentué dans des
proportions qu'on n'avait jamais vu
jusqu'à présent
il ya eu dans un premier temps et puis
très profond et aujourd'hui ce mépris
s'est traduit par une compassion et
l'association en tout cas factuel mais
qui est encore loin malheureusement
d'être un véritable échange
on nous impose beaucoup de choses on
conserve pour la forme mais en réalité
les décisions qui sont prises sont
généralement ce qui a déjà été actée à
paris avant une annonce alors les
habitants des alpes-maritimes comme les
habitants du nord vont être confiné pour
les deux prochains
week-end ça fait plus d'un an que des
mesures de restriction sont mises en
place un peu partout en france comment
ont réagi vos administrés ont rejoint un
petit peu le problème
on a avec les élus locaux c'est à dire
que les citoyens quand on est mis devant
le fait accompli sans avertissement
malheureusement il ya toujours une
réaction de différence il ya la
compréhension il ya énormément de
discipline et beaucoup l'énorme majorité
on sert ce qu'il faut malheureusement il
ya toujours une minorité qui elle ne
veut rien respecter et à qui on dit dans
l'incapacité d'imposer quoi que ce soit
parce que justement on n'a pas les
moyens d'aller dans les quartiers très
sensibles à ces défaillances est en
réalité comme on n'explique pas les
choses on met devant le fait accompli et
qu'on est capable de faire en six heures
linverse absolue de ce qu'on dit depuis
des semaines ça n'a pas besoin de le
confiner que le couvre-feu à 18 heures
ça suffit que la situation est sous
contrôle et même ça arrange que la
vaccination ce qui sont encore d'un coup
on vous dit ballon finalement la
situation échappe à tout contrôle il
faut conseiller le week-end et ont par
contre on peut pas vous donner de
vaccins mais je vous en ai apporté
catherine 500 doses oui c'est pas très
sérieux merci beaucoup sébastien l'avoir
d'avoir été avec moi cet après midi sur
ft france je rappelle que vous êtes mère
l est républicain de mandelieu à la
napoule merci beaucoup